Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the new Incredibles
2 trailer for Pixar easter eggs, things you
might have missed, plus a theory about the
villain reveal.
I'm also starting a giveaway for an awesome
Incredibles 2 Funko Pop.
You just need to be a subscriber and leave
me a comment about the movie for a chance
to win.
I'm going to start with the meeting at the
Devtech building where Mr Incredible, Elastigirl
and Frozone are being introduced to Winston
Deavor.
Remember in the sneak peek that Frozone mentioned
he'd been approached to set up just such a
meeting.
"I was approached by this tycoon."
"Wants to talk ... about hero stuff."
Notice that in this scene, Mr Incredible and
Elastigirl are actually wearing their original
early costumes from the first movie before
Edna Mode made them the iconic red suits we're
more used to seeing them in.
And notice that when Winston Deavor pitches
his idea to bring the Supers back into public
favour, he's showing a picture of the Incredibles
family being led away by a police officer.
From the backdrop of the picture, it looks
like it might be during the aftermath of the
Underminer's rampage.
There seems to be a lot of public damage and
destruction that happens during the Incredibles'
fight with the Underminer, and it sounds like
public opinion might be quite anti-Supers
even if the Parr family did succeed in taking
down the villain.
There are also some very cool action shots
in the new trailer and I want to particularly
examine this shot of Dash.
The young speedster is running through portals
that take him through solid objects.
I think this could be the work of a new character
called Voyd who, according to the official
description for her character, has "the ability
to divert and manipulate objects around her
by creating voids that allow the objects to
appear and disappear."
Voyd hasn't shown up yet in the trailers,
but her character description also states
she's "a 'wannabe' Super and a mega-fan of
Elastigirl."
But what's also interesting in this scene
is that Dash appears to be running in a never-ending
loop.
You can see an image of Dash running through
the same portal over and over in the distance.
Now, judging by Voyd's character description,
it sounds like she'd be friendly to our band
of superheroes, but what if she's actually
a villain in disguise, masquerading as a fan
of Elastigirl?
Could she have trapped Dash in an endless
loop of sorts?
Or maybe she is really on their side and created
this loop accidentally.
A possible alternative is that these portals
are being created by Jack-Jack who has a ton
of superpowers.
In fact, we've already seen him teleport himself
before now, including in another scene in
this trailer.
And I wonder, if like me, those scenes made
you think a bit of the mutant Blink in X-Men:
Days of Future Past and also Vibe in TV's
The Flash.
It also looks like Violet is getting some
new powers in the sequel to go with her adolescent
angst.
As well as being able to create forcefield
energy shields that can protect her family,
there's a moment during what looks like the
Underminer sequence where she seems to cast
force blades or blasts that take out a piece
of falling rubble saving the people below.
OK, let's get to the big villain reveal from
the trailer.
"The Screenslaver interrupts this program
for an important announcement."
It looks like his dastardly plan will be hypnotising
and mind-controlling people via their TV screens.
Elastigirl already seems to be aware of his
plan as notice how she's shielding her eyes
from the screens in the background here.
This is happening at the local TV station
and I think this is going to tie in with the
scene earlier in the trailer where Elastigirl
attacks an escaping helicopter.
A recent Incredibles 2 LEGO set has an "Elastigirl
Rooftop Pursuit" scene which shows that Screenslaver
is indeed the person piloting the helicopter
which also has a spinning hypno-propeller
that can hypnotise you if you look at it.
And there's some evidence now which I think
ties Screenslaver with the head of the Devtech
corporation Winston Deavor.
Firstly, the shape of Screenslaver's head
seems to match that of Winston's.
And, secondly, think about what business Devtech
is involved in: It's a telecommunications
company.
In fact, the LEGO set mentions that Screenslaver
is trying to hack into a satellite dish on
the roof of a building.
And that LEGO set building is likely the same
TV building as in the trailer.
On top of that, Winston has a sister called
Evelyn, who is the tech brainchild behind
the business.
What's more as I mentioned in my breakdown
of the Olympics trailer, Evelyn Deavor could
be pronounced "Evil Endeavour", even if that's
a little on the nose, all of which gives me
the impression that these two could be up
to no good.
There's also something fishy about the tycoon's
plan to recruit Elastigirl and there's a possible
hint at that in the recent Edna Mode teaser.
"I'm not all dark and angsty."
"I'm Elastigirl."
"Edna designed this?"
"No!
Some guy named Alexander Galbachy."
I'm not sure if all these evil hints and links
to Devtech feel a little too obvious so perhaps
there'll be a further twist in the movie a
bit like we got with Coco, but at the moment,
I'm definitely getting some dodgy vibes from
Winston.
By the way, it looks like this scene is happening
in the city of New Urbem as you can spot part
of a sign for a "New Urbem Savings & Loan"
bank in the distance.
New Urbem is a new location that will be introduced
in Incredibles 2.
There are also some Pixar easter eggs and
call backs in the trailer which I want to
talk about.
"What!"
"Is this all vegetables?!"
"Who ordered all the vegetables?!"
"I did."
The shot of a mountain of broccoli on Dash's
plate as he complains about his mum ordering
a vegetable takeout dish is a hat-tip to Inside
Out and Riley's aversion to eating that particular
vegetable.
"Hold on, guys."
"It's broccoli!"
"Yucky!"
"Well, I just saved our lives."
"Yeah.
You're welcome."
And those Chinese takeout containers are also
another Pixar easter egg as the same style
of food box has been used a number of times
in other Pixar movies.
The first time was in A Bug's Life where it
was called the "Chinese Cabinet of Metamorphosis".
It's also appeared in the Pizza Planet Truck
in Toy Story 2, in Linguini's apartment in
Ratatouille, and it was also in Inside out
where, just like the Parr family, Riley and
the Andersens sat down for a dinner of Chinese
takeout.
One of the most memorable moments in the first
movie was when Frozone went to get his supersuit
so he could join the fight against Syndrome
and then this happened.
"Honey?"
"HONEY: What?
"Where is my supersuit?"
"HONEY: What?"
"HONEY: I put it away.2
"Where?"
"HONEY: Why do you need to know?"
"I need it!"
"HONEY: Don't you think about running off
doing no derrin'-do."
"We are talking about the greater good."
"HONEY: 'Greater good'?
I am your wife!"
"I'm the greatest good you are ever gonna
get!"
So, it was just fantastic to discover that
this time he's got his suit at the ready;
although, by the sound of it, his wife Honey
still isn't overly keen on her husband's superhero
shenanigans.
"Suit up, it might get weird!"
"I'll be there, asap!"
"HONEY: Where you going asap?!
You better be back asap!"
Now, what do you think about the new Incredibles
2 trailer?
And do you have any theories on the villain
or was there anything I missed?
Be sure to subscribe and leave me a comment
for your chance to win an awesome Incredibles
2 Funko Pop.
The winner of my Art of Coco Pixar giveaway
is on the screen right now, so if that's you
private message me with your details and I'll
get back to you.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate a
like and you can tap the screen for my latest
Pixar and Disney videos.
Thanks for watching and see you next time.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!